joining me now is arkansas senator tom
cotton who sits
on the armed services committee
um senator absent
control of the senate because you don't
have control of the senate at this
moment
given the dire situation that we're
facing what can and should republicans
do right now
to address what is a 9-1-1 emergency
well laura we hope to win back control
this fall so we can begin to get to the
bottom of a lot of what's been happening
in this pentagon whether it's the
foolish and wasted
witch hunt looking for so-called
extremists or some of the challenges
that you outline in our recruiting but
i've taken steps already earlier in this
congress i demanded that all officers
being promoted to the general ranks ask
ask answer a series of simple questions
like do they believe the constitution
the declaration is racist or do they
believe that a skin color should be a
primary consideration for promotion in
the military and i said if they get it
wrong i'm not going to wave their
nomination through and i've got a lot of
feedback from the officer corps that is
filtered down and the message is being
sent that they should not be engaged in
those kind of politically charged issues
that we need a professional officer
corps that does not get engaged in
politics in any way and is focused on
the military sole mission which is
fighting and winning our nation's wars
so right now unless you guys have the
senate you have the majority in the
senate there's there's nothing
i mean you've written the letter you've
asked them the questions but there's
nothing else you guys can do because
last time i checked every republican is
voting for this massive increase in
military spending given all the things
that we're seeing out there in the
pentagon
well no laura there's more that we can
do as well in addition to the oversight
hearings that we always have that we can
push our senior military leaders on
these questions there is just pointing
out the annual defense bill i voted
against that this year in committee just
like i voted against it last year in
committee because it had so much of this
left-wing social engineering i'm not
just going to vote for something because
they slap defense on it and i don't
think a lot of our troops want us to
either now in the end we were able to
strip out almost all of those provisions
and i was able to support it in the end
i hope to do that again this year but
i'm not going to vote for a bill that
for instance requires women to enter the
draft something that is massively
unpopular with the american people to
include women in america again our
military is not a jobs program
it's not designed to engage in social
engineering it's designed to fight and
win our nation's wars and as you
outlined at the beginning we face a
recruiting crisis as bad as it's been
since vietnam that's not because there's
a strong economy we've had strong
economies before it's because so many
kids who might join the army or the
marine corps the navy the air force
see some of these controversies they
hear about it from people on active duty
and they decide that maybe they don't
want to do it right now i mean kids who
are thinking about joining our military
military they want to learn how to kill
bad guys they don't want to learn how to
use the right pronouns right into that
into that point senator uh here's the
air force chief of staff today
detailing
one of their so-called top priorities
watch
the one thing about george fully's death
as tragic as it has been
is open up our nation to conversation
the key part is not that we talk about
it's the things that we're doing to
work diversity inclusion we got to
resource it we got to put money behind
it if it requires money we got to put
personnel behind it
we could have leadership involvement and
we've been doing that
senator
climate change
really
yeah the these are not the priorities of
an 18 year old that wants to join our
military our military is already one of
the most diverse
we're paying for this but our military
is already one of the most diverse
institutions in america when i served on
active duty we had blacks we had latinos
asians whites what mattered to us was
not the color of our skin it was the red
white and blue that we all wore on our
shoulder
and but when you hear this from from
these liberals who want to neuter the
military year after year that the
military is full of
racial extremists and sexual predators
that it produces all these
uh
traumatized fragile eggshells that
america is not a country that we should
be proud of and be willing to fight for
we shouldn't be surprised that young men
and women are reluctant to sign up for
our military
the cia director referenced the issue of
the climate watch
i think we have the biggest existential
threat in many ways is climate change so
it is our responsibility to help
policymakers in the u.s government
understand the consequences of climate
change he created as part of a new
mission center a unit that's focused on
these issues we've expanded its staff
so
this is what our cia is pushing the air
force is pushing the diversity equity
inclusion agenda what do you think
china's thinking watching all of this
can they actually believe this is going
to be
this is this is the united states of
america
china's probably laughing that a major
uh political party and its chief uh
enemy the democratic party wants to
hamstring hamstring
uh oil and gas production in which we're
the world's leader and they want to
empower so-called green energy
technology which china is the world
leader of that would be their national
strategy but you know climate change is
not the single biggest existential
crisis that we face the biggest
existential crisis we face is that china
wants to replace us as a world
superpower and they are rapidly building
out their nuclear forces that may one
day overmatch our nuclear forces that's
a real
existential crisis well senator i hope
we certainly get to the bottom of this
recruitment crisis in the military this
from the vaccine mandate to the wokeness
to i mean this is every this is all we
should be talking about and i appreciate
your pressing them on all these issues
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else